thank you for making this show special
and being here oh man well thank you for
having me and allowing me to make it
special all right
all right right yes how special can i
make it i can do like
making your own you're a producer i know
so yeah pretty much whatever i want to
do to make it my own
i'm leaning in watch me lean in whatever
i want yes
okay i mean you know conditions i mean
no exact but if it's
whatever i want okay uh
just like as a test if i wanted it to
make it like a different
a different color out here can i mess
with you vibe we can darren come on help
him out
can you give me something red because i
feel sexy i feel hot
you feeling red red light special tlc
something right
hey hey there we go all right i like the
red light special i like that
little red light special yes huh yeah
kate heart like
i like the night it was a good song i
mean i came out to like some good music
but i feel like you know there's a
little more
there's a little more umph that i would
have had if i could have you know if i
could have asked for something
a little more drum i got a little more
drum you're looking for
okay okay okay
[Music]
go ahead i did the electric flat there
at the end
older older you get the less space you
take up right here
it looks like i'm doing a bunch i'm i'm
in my box i'm not going outside
my box right here hey i like it i like
it i like that too and i can do this
pretty much throughout the show yeah
okay you're a show today with me done of
course yes done save it more
what do you think about the title the
kelly clarkson show do you think we
should do something with that yeah i
mean if
it's my show then i don't i don't know i
just showed you i don't think it should
just be your name so let's change
okay put my name in there too okay
somehow like the kevin
the kevin the kevin hart kevin hart's
kevin hart's
kelly clarkson show something like that
yeah okay your name first yeah put my
name first yeah your name for assistant
it's good okay it's still leaning in
here
we're talking about it that's what i'm
talking about all right change it they
change the graphic change it yes they
did
kevin hearts there it is right at the
top there we go
top line i got it i got it i like it
okay well now we're also like here to
talk about fatherhood
okay so like maybe we should honor that
somehow we should
uh uh hold on can we do like a graphic
going to that because i took
notes oh you took it yeah i got like
little notes like oh okay
something like uh kevin hart's like uh i
don't know like fathers and kids or
something like that
okay like something something with me
like driving conversation toward that so
just
put put something in there too of like
okay a tribute to red dead okay
tribute to rap dad okay all right who
who is doing that because i like him
we are good our show we are emmy-winning
so right when you say it it just
happens i like that i like that uh i
mean the other thing
i don't know occasionally can i get hit
with a spotlight you got a spotlight
spotlight yes we have a spotlight if i
want to get hit with a spotlight yeah
every now and then just to where i'm
just nodding it this is where we can
kind of dull you out a little bit
hit me with a spotlight every now and
then when i'm talking
and just make sure there's a big
lighting difference between me
and kelly there you go yeah yeah let
them know who is important yeah just
sometimes when i talk i may just want a
spotlight just to
i know it adds to what i'm saying okay
it makes it feel more powerful it makes
me feel like
okay yeah see like look see my stance
change adam's spotlight is there
welcome welcome hey welcome to kevin
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help